messieurs dames bon soin
c'est un véritable plaisir d'être avec
vous ce soir pour vous parler d'un sujet
d'actualité qui est là la chirurgie
robotique sujets d'actualité avec des
questions qui se pose actuellement est
ce que la chirurgie robotique et le
robot chirurgical et d'un instrument est
ce que le robot chirurgical est un jouet
un gadget met à disposition des
chirurgiens alors est-ce un instrument
la réponse est positive le robot
chirurgical est un instrument qui est
mis à disposition des chirurgiens pour
pouvoir réaliser des interventions
chirurgicales
est ce que le robot chirurgical est un
gadget on peut se poser la question de
ce côté là bon ça ferait cher quand même
le gadget puisqu'il faut savoir qu'un
robot actuellement c'est un peu plus de
deux millions d'euros c'est quand même
des somme excessive avec une maintenance
assez importante donc ce sont des gros
investissement mais conceptuellement il
faut savoir que le robot chirurgical
s'approche un petit peu de l'idée que
l'on a du jeu actuellement à savoir que
le chirurgien va être assis
confortablement va être au niveau de sa
console et va utiliser des joystick
donc vous voyez que la console de jeux
dit c'est des salons des jeunes ados
actuellement peut se rapprocher de ce
côté mais l'analogie entre les deux
s'arrête là alors pour parler de
chirurgie robotique
nous allons faire un petit voyage un
sacré voyage dans le temps puisque on va
partir de l'homme préhistorique qui est
utilisé du silex un couteau à silex et
puis au fur et à mesure du temps les
instruments chirurgicaux se sont
améliorées ça c'est une scie qui était
utilisée au xviie siècle pour réaliser
des amputations et ensuite l'évolution
des instruments s'est fait rapidement
avec parfois des instruments un peu
cocasse pour arriver à ce que l'on fait
actuellement avec surtout cette image
qui correspond une table d'intervention
chirurgicale classique existe partout
dans le monde et nous allons arriver
progressivement à ce nouveau concept
chirurgicale qui est la chirurgie
robotique
alors dès mésolithique c'est à dire 12
mille ans avant jésus-christ les hommes
pratiquaient sur le crâne de leurs
congénères des actes chirurgicaux
ici on voit sur ces deux crânes d'hommes
préhistoriques des gestes chirurgicaux
qui avait été fait à l'époque à l'aide
d'instruments de silex et on peut dire
après analyses sur ces crânes que les
personnes avaient survécu
la cicatrisation osseuse nous prouve que
ces gens avaient survécu ce qui nous
montre aussi que l'homme à cette époque
avec des instruments assez basique
faisait des gestes relativement agressif
relativement pointue avec des taux de
survie assez important c'est assez
étonnant
pourquoi ces gestes étaient faits alors
c'est toujours sujet à conjectures
rituel d'habitude particulière d'être
probablement pour soulager les humains
quoi qu'il en soit la chirurgie
robotique dans l'état actuel en tout cas
dans les années dans les années 40
faisait partie encore du domaine de la
science-fiction
robo't à leterme robot vient d'un terme
tchèque
robo't à qui signifie une corvée un
travail obligatoire
tu as donné la première fois que le
terme chirurgie robotique est apparu
c'est asimov c'est un écrivain un
écrivain américano russe qui a utilisé
pour la première fois ce terme en 1941
ce n'est pas si loin mais à l'époque
nous étions encore dans le domaine de la
science fiction ce qui a permis le
développement de la robotique en général
initialement c'est surtout à l'époque
industrielle avec des robots
relativement uniment terme est assez
sophistiqué pour permettre à l'homme de
pouvoir réaliser des gestes compliqués
difficiles etc
mais surtout c'est surtout l'impact
sociétal l'impact sociétal de la
robotique en général qui a donné une
explosion assez importante du
développement de la robotique l'impact
société à qui permettait à l'homme
de l'extirper d'environnement au style
l'espace la conquête de l'espace
la manipulation de produits extrêmement
dangereux de produits radioactifs mais
il ya eu aussi une dérive puisque
certains robots ont été développés à
peser guerrière dont l'objectif initial
est différent un peu de celui kazim of
avait décrit dans ses différentes revues
dans ses différents dans ses différentes
dans ses différents bouquin ce que l'on
peut retenir c'est globalement il existe
trois grandes étapes à la chirurgie
moderne
la première étape milieu du 19e siècle
s'est lâché en j'ai ouvert qui se
pratiquait dans de grandes salles à
grand chirurgien grande cicatrice
première étape
ensuite la chirurgie a évolué et
évoluent vers une technique qui a permis
d'obtenir des modifications assez
important dans la prise en charge des
patients c'est la laparoscopie à l'enjeu
et m'expliquer pour que tout le monde
comprend bien la laparoscopie c'est de
la chirurgie mais c'est de la chirurgie
qui se fait de manière moins invasive
moins agressive au lieu d'avoir une
cicatrice importante au niveau de la
paroi abdominale on va travailler à
travers de petits orifices qui sont
faits au niveau de l'abdomen et à
travers ses orifices seront introduit
des instruments qui permettront aux
chirurgiens de pouvoir travailler de
réaliser des gestes
ce n'est pas si vieux 19 188 premier
cholécystectomie alors ya des termes
médicaux qui sont souvent barbares la
cholécystectomie c'est une glande que
nous avons sous le foie qui est la
vésicule biliaire et la cholécystectomie
et l'acte chirurgical qui consiste à
retirer la vésicule biliaire de
l'abdomen
donc ce sont des gestes qui sont fait
couramment il faut savoir ce geste de
cholécystectomie en 1988 c'est pas si
loin et est un geste déjà assez avant
gardiste qui est pratiqué actuellement
dans le monde de manière tout à fait
régulière et 1997 le premier cas de
change premier cachet en j call mondial
où une intervention a été réalisé
complètement par voix robotique
alors parler de la chirurgie robotique
un samedi soir c'est pas évident
j'aurais pu vous présenter des études
scientifiques extrêmement intéressante
avec des tas de chiffres les avantages
les inconvénients c'est un débat
actuellement que beaucoup de chirurgiens
ont que beaucoup de scientifiques ont
mais pour comprendre l'intérêt
fondamental je pense que ce petit ces
petites photos nous permettent de voir
un petit peu tous toutes les étapes que
nous avons pu franchir
première étape l'open chez angers la
chirurgie à ciel ouvert celle que l'on
conçoit classiquement donc le chirurgien
sont malades et de cette façon le
challenge et êtes à côté de son malade
et va pratiquer donc une incision avec
un instrument il va travailler avec ses
mains et des instruments à l'intérieur
de l'abdomen
c'est la chirurgie moderne première
étape qui s'est développée tout le long
du xixème siècle et nous sommes passés à
la chirurgie laparoscopique la chirurgie
laparoscopique c'est donc de la
chirurgie qui se fait par
l'intermédiaire de petits orifices et
dans ces tubes au niveau de ses orifices
on va introduire des instruments qui
vont nous permettre de faire des gestes
chirurgicaux extrêmement précis or
l'intérêt entre cette étape est celle ci
est importante
l'intérêt est essentielle en pour le
patient ces petits orifices vont
entraîner - douleur ce qui fait mal dans
une intervention chirurgicale
ce n'est pas à l'intérieur de l'abdomen
et c'est surtout la paroisse plus là
l'incision niveau pariétal est
importante plus les douleurs seront
importantes
donc là ça a permis de diminuer les
douleurs post opératoires
ça permet aussi aux patients de quitter
plus rapidement l'hôpital
ça permet aussi impatient de reprendre
une activité professionnelle beaucoup
plus rapidement et ensuite changé à ciel
ouvert chirurgie laparoscopique on est
arrivé à la chirurgie robotisée la
chirurgie robotisée pour résumer c'est
de la chirurgie
laparoscopique assistée par ordinateur
et là vous voyez que le chirurgien n'est
plus debout à côté de son patient mais
confortablement assis sur une console
avec une vision tridimensionnelle et des
gestes intuitifs
alors me direz-vous et sa cellule au
coeur du débat actuellement c'est
qu'elle est l'avantagent de la chirurgie
robotique comparativement à la chirurgie
laparoscopique premièrement c'est la
vision faut savoir que la chirurgie
laparoscopique le chirurgien comme vous
l'avez vue est assis et debout à côté de
son patient avec des instruments 2 me de
cette façon le chirurgien va regarder un
écran qui est face à lui
cet écran ne va lui donner que deux
informations le haut le bas la droite la
gauche il n'aura pas une information
extrêmement importante qui est la
profondeur donc ça c'est très très
important c'est un élément fondamental
que la chirurgie robotique amène au
chirurgien est ce que l'on peut faire
actuellement des gestes de chirurgie
laparoscopique difficile et long oui ces
gestes là sont faits toute l'année dans
de nombreux pays dans le monde
le deuxième avantage qui est un avantage
fondamental c'est la gestuelle faut
savoir qu'en chirurgie laparoscopique
vous allez donc pardon vous allez donc
travaillé avec donc des instruments qui
sont glissés à l'intérieur de l'abdomen
dans des trocarts mais vous allez devoir
utiliser des gestes qui sont anti
physiologique qui ne sont pas normaux
c'est à dire que le chirurgien qui va
être dans cette situation qui a
différentes [ __ ] à ses pieds pour
l'électricité le laser etc va devoir
donc être de cette façon pendant des
heures à regarder un écran où il n'y
aura qu'une vision en deux dimensions et
va réaliser des gestes complètement anti
physiologique c'est à dire que vous avez
un bras de levier lorsque je veux aller
à gauche
je vais devoir pousser mon instrument
sur la droite
c'est relativement difficile est ce que
c'est possible de faire des
interventions difficiles de cette façon
oui le problème n'est pas là mais
en chirurgie robotique le mouvement va
être complètement simplifiée c'est à
dire que les mouvements chez hengy coûts
qui sont faits par le chirurgiens vont
être transmis aux instruments de manière
intuitive et reproduire la mobilité du
chirurgien de sa main par
l'intermédiaire d'instruments dans tous
les plans des espaces à l'intérieur on
voit donc l'intérêt fondamental
or pour bien comprendre
on va passer donc ces différentes étapes
le ch et angers un seydou vert qui fait
donc des interventions avec des grandes
cicatrices à l'époque on disait à grand
chirurgie à grande cicatrice la
chirurgie laparoscopique c'est un peu
comme un équilibriste alors le
chirurgien est à côté de son patient
il a les mains de cette façon il regarde
l'écran qui est en face de lui et il va
jouer de cette façon pendant des heures
est il possible de faire un geste
compliqué de cette façon oui il est
beaucoup plus facile de faire ce geste
de cette façon confortablement installé
dans un fauteuil avec un environnement
tridimensionnelle et une gestualité à
l'intérieur de l'abdomen qui reproduit
les mouvements du poignet des doigts
duché engins de manière extrêmement
précis c'est comme si vous preniez
l'image d'un d'une jeune femme ou d'un
jeune homme qui essaie d'apprendre à
conduire
donc on va lui dire tu vas apprendre à
conduire tu va donc rentrer dans ton
véhicule tu ne seras pas à si tu vas
devoir être debout
ensuite quand tu va conduire tu vas
avoir ton pare brise et tu vas voir le
haut le bas la droite la gauche mais tu
n'auras pas la notion de profondeur
ensuite on va lui dire pour conduire si
tu as envie d'aller à gauche ça va être
possible mais il va falloir tourner le
volant à droite
tous ces éléments tous ces éléments
l'analogie peut vous paraître un peu
excessive
c'est exactement ça
alors actuellement on peut se dire
pourquoi un robot chirurgical à
dunkerque un robot de dernière
génération
sachant que par exemple la semaine
dernière le un robot a été installé dans
l'une des plus grandes structures de
cancérologie européenne à paris on s'est
posé la question à ce que monter un
projet robotics est pas un projet
personnel c'est un projet commun qui
nécessite de multiples personnes qui
sont convaincus
nous nous sommes dit un robot à
dunkerque
oui pourquoi pas si on part du principe
que la santé pas de prix je vous rassure
c'est un concept qui est complètement
faux mais si on part de ce principe nous
sommes dit frein est un frein financier
le projet nous allons monter alors pour
comprendre la chirurgie robotique il est
plus facile de montrer et les
chirurgiens travaillent beaucoup comme
ça des images je suis désolé pour les
personnes un peu sensible fait comme ça
pour éviter de voir les choses qui
pourraient éventuellement vous choquer
alors ça c'est de la chirurgie c'est la
vraie vie c'est au bloc opératoire c'est
juste à côté donc actuellement une salle
de chirurgie au bloc opératoire vous
avez des écrans partout des ordinateurs
beaucoup de personnes qui s'affairent
autour des anesthésistes des infirmières
etc
mais le principe en est le même on est
obligé quoi qu'il en soit de faire des
gestes un peu invasif c'est à dire faire
des orifices au niveau de la paroi
abdominale pour pouvoir rentrer nos
instruments
c'est la première étape d origine moi je
trouve ça très beau peu choquant mais je
peux concevoir qu'on puisse choquer donc
ça c'est une intervention classique pour
une exérèse d'une glande cancéreuses
donc c'est un patient qui avait un
cancer dont première étape on rentre des
instruments à l'époque avant la
chirurgie robotique qui est fait dans la
grande majorité la chirurgie
laparoscopique qui est fait dans la
grande majorité des cas de cette façon
on ne met pas de robot ici il ya cette
particularité qu'à voir après avoir mis
les trocarts ces instruments jamar les
bras du robot à ces différentes rocha
donc c'est une étape assez importante où
l'on fixe les bras du robot il en a
quatre
sur les différents instruments ensuite
je doit introduire les instruments et
ses instruments sont introduits sous
contrôle de la vue donc voilà on
introduit un ciseau une pince bon peu
importe une source laser et ses
instruments voiliers sont introduits
sous contrôle de la vue avec une
parfaite sécurité
mais nous sommes encore en deux
dimensions au bas à droite gauche ça ce
sont des ciseaux avait vu ses six ou
vont reproduire à l'intérieur de
l'abdomen tous les mouvements intuitifs
du poignet et lorsque ces instruments
sont mises en place à dure quelques
minutes
le chirurgien au lieu de rester à côté
de son patient va quitter les lieux
laissés là la révolution le chirurgien
va partir et aller rejoindre sa console
de travail sa console de travail où il
va pouvoir manipuler les différents
éléments des bras du robot de
l'extérieur c'est difficile au début
pour le chirurgien de quitter son
patient
ce qu'on a un sentiment de sécurité
lorsqu'on est à côté de son patient et
voyez il va devoir gérer sur ce cockpit
à la fois différentes sources
différentes [ __ ] la caméra le clutch
les différentes sources d'électricité
éventuellement des lasers qui peuvent
être combinées il va donc gérer ça aussi
par l'intermédiaire de petites pinces où
l'on introduit ses doigts
ce sont des joystick voyez donc la
l'analogie avec les jeux des vidéos peut
se comprendre à ce niveau et par ces
intermédiaires donc lille et
confortablement ainsi donc au bloc
opératoire
il peut faire avec une vision très
dimensionnelle des gerbes des gestes
chirurgicaux extrêmement précis donc mon
propos n'est pas de dire que l'une des
techniques est meilleur que l'autre non
mon propos est de dire que la
technologie doit aider le chirurgien
dans l'intérêt du patient réaliser des
gestes de plus en plus précis mais aussi
dans l'intérêt du chirurgien avec une
ergonomie satisfaisante et opéré de
cette façon avec des gestes fluides nous
permet de faire des choses beaucoup plus
longue beaucoup plus précise et sans
tremblement
il reste encore 30 secondes je pense que
je serai dans les temps voilà donc vous
voyez c'est la taille du pizou c'est la
moitié petit doigt alors ça c'est
l'intérêt fondamental de la chirurgie
ont reproduit énormément de choses à
ciel ouvert ce qui nous permet de faire
des choses beaucoup plus précise est
beaucoup plus intéressante alors le
frein de la chirurgie actuellement le
frein de la chirurgie robotique et le
développement de la chirurgie robotique
en général c'est essentiellement un
frein financier comme je voulais je
voulais dit au début
l'acquisition d'un robot chirurgical
nécessite un investissement extrêmement
important c'est un projet qui nécessite
donc différentes sollicitations pour
obtenir les fonds dont le frein
fondamental c'est un frein financier
l'avenir de la chirurgie c'est un avenir
que j'espère rose
on ne va plus faire marche arrière la
chirurgie robotique va se développer
et si l'on parle de robotique en général
l'idéal c'est d'être un peu fidèle à ce
que azim of avait dit c'est que
l'intéressé d'améliorer la condition
humaine
si celle inverse je n'adhère pas
je vous remercie